trappes une ville qui le passionne
encore c'est ce qui a motivé guy
malandain 82 ans à être de nouveau
candidat dans la ville où il est maire
depuis 2001
pour son premier meeting de campagne à
la salle picasso l'élu a présenté sa
liste et les enjeux importants pour
trappe dans les années à venir
les thématiques sur lesquelles il
souhaite continuer d'apporter son
expérience et a besoin de continuer au
plan humain social éducatif urbanistique
etc
il ya besoin de continuer de poursuivre
la politique qui a été menée jusqu'ici
pour pour terminer alors terminé veut
pas dire qu'il faudra rien faire il ya
encore des choses qui me tiennent à
coeur des sujets comme l'enfouissement
de la nationale 10 les travaux ont
démarré et guy malandain va les suivre
de près pour suivre aussi la rénovation
urbaine avec le secteur cités nouvelles
barbus et le square camus le pôle gare
également et le nouveau quartier
programmé à la halle freyssinet
enfin développer encore des projets
autour de l'éducation trap a été retenu
récemment dans le dispositif national
des sites et éducative il faut continuer
à approfondir tout ce que l'on fait pour
tirer la jeunesse vers le haut on est en
train de réussir conserve le modèle à
beaucoup je suis immodeste en disant ça
mais de temps en temps il faut savoir
reconnaître ce que font les services et
bien aussi la population qui contribue à
tout ça moi je trouve que on arrive au
troisième mandat avec quelque chose
d'inespéré cette réunion était la
première d'un cycle de huit rencontres
avec les habitants avant le premier tour
des municipales fixées le 15 mars
prochain face à guy malandain trois
autres listes se sont également déclarés
pour le scrutin dans la ville